hola hola
[Música]
aquí
preparada para compartir con ustedes
ay
un estado generalizado de
y malestar
miedo ansiedad
angustia tristeza
muchos de nosotros
dormimos diferente a colom no hacíamos
antes nos sentimos diferentes
sin embargo también reconocemos la
belleza de las cosas simples
pero esta pandemia ha erosionado la
salud mental de muchos de nosotros
un rasgo fundamental
darnos cuenta
poner bajo la lupa conceptos reflexiones
porque son las acciones que hacemos
nosotros lo que determina nuestro vivir
hay un estado generalizado de malestar y
les quiero compartir algunas
que espero que nos sirvan para vivir un
poquito mejor
la mayoría de nosotros creo yo tenemos
algunos recursos agua caliente
una hogar comida por lo tanto el estado
y bienestar en nuestro caso es un estado
su objetivo
porque podemos hacer cosas para estar
mejor eso es lo que vamos a buscar
compartir y quiero aclarar que esta
conversación esta charla que vamos a
tener hoy no suplanta la ayuda
terapéutica sino muy por el contrario si
te das cuenta que necesitas que te
ayuden pedirlo
una de las causas que nos llevan al
malestar es la incertidumbre
es posible gestionar la incertidumbre
hay un estado de incertidumbre óptimo
por ejemplo que el que yo sentía antes
de salir de ahí
sentía incertidumbre pero en un estado
que me desafiaba
adrenalina cortisol diciendo adelante
pero hay otro estado de incertidumbre
que nos daña que nos hace mal que
despierta la ansiedad entonces es
posible gestionar la incertidumbre
la primera pregunta podríamos decir es
posible vivir sin incertidumbre no
es posible gestionar la si
acá quiero dar un concepto que para mí
es fundamental dividir
la gestión del control
nosotros queremos controlar y el
controlar nos despierta muchas veces
enojo miedo es querer que las cosas sean
de un modo determinado en cambio la
gestión abre posibilidades
la vida por cierto
desafiante
asombrosa muchas veces dolorosa la vida
es incierta la vida es en permanencia
relacionó esto con el concepto del líder
líder se nace o se hace me he pasado
mucho tiempo en mi vida
reflexionando sobre esto es más cuando
fundamos la universidad siglo 21
decíamos formando líderes
y discutíamos si se hacía se nacía o se
hacía creo que hay un concepto
equivocado sobre el liderazgo el
liderazgo uno es tener seguidores no es
ser jefe el liderazgo es influir sobre
todo y la primera influencia que tenemos
que tener sobre nuestra propia vida
generar acciones para lograr resultados
quien no se ve como líder no se hace
protagonista de su historia ojalá todos
en la barca del vivir
llevemos nuestro timón
la incertidumbre falta de certezas y que
produce la incertidumbre incomodidad
y la incomodidad
las reprimimos la mayoría de las veces
queremos que dice parezca que no es que
hay que se vaya y mi invitación es todo
lo contrario ante la incomodidad a
bríttes
déjala y escucharla porque la incómoda
es como esto como un termómetro que se
está informando algo te está diciendo
algo a la incomodidad hay que
escucharlas para decir que lo estás
diciendo
desde la incomodidad muchas veces va a
aparecer la duda
y la duda es natural
cuando nuestra mente está preocupada
tendemos a varias cosas a hacer pero
medio detener en dos a rumiar o
castástrofes a rumiar es como las vacas
que pasamos el mismo pensamiento una y
otra vez una y otra vez te pasó
catastróficas es imaginarte que se ahora
las cosas están mal y en el futuro van a
estar peor rumiamos y catástrofes amos
de modo natural dudamos de modo natural
la duda es un proceso racional pero
podemos gestionarla
ante la duda que podemos hacer
me voy a permitir darte algunas ideas
recordando que vos sos líder y que podés
gestionar las ideas van a trabajar en
tres dominios principalmente el dominio
del pensamiento el dominio de la emoción
y el dominio del cuerpo porque estos
tres dominios se interrelacionan de
acuerdo a lo que pienso
se despierta una emoción de acorde a la
emoción que tengo mi cuerpo libera todo
procesos neurofisiológicos y empieza a
liberar ya prepararme en mi cuerpo para
responder vamos a trabajar en estos tres
dominios algunas ideas de estas tres
dominas vamos a empezar con un dominio
muy presente en nosotros
las palabras escuchas tus palabras a las
palabras no se lo lleva el viento
todo proceso de pensamientos se deben en
palabras toda palabra establece
pensamientos vivimos en auto charlas y
la mayoría de ellas no son buenas no nos
dicen nada bueno nos hablan del pasado o
nos hablan del futuro nos tratamos mal
escucha tus palabras
escuchar lo que decís porque una gran
investigadora tara branch dice
las palabras son los vientos
las emociones son las olas de acuerdo a
tus palabras vas a subir o bajar tu o la
emocional escucha tu palabra tratarte
bien
una competencia para mí muy importante y
saber pedir somos muy incompetentes en
el pedir
quien no pide se exige
manipula o manda aprendamos a pedir
somos seres interdependientes el pedido
nos colabora en los estados de
incertidumbre escuchas tus emociones las
emociones son simples señales no son ni
buenas ni malas nos dicen que algo está
sucediendo y nos llevan a ciertos
comportamientos las emociones puede
gestionarse las emociones restrictivas
que nosotros conocemos como negativas
generalmente nos aíslan las emociones
expansivas que nosotros conocemos como
positivas son conectores para mostrar un
poquito acá y quiero entrar en una
principalmente en esta en el miedo
ha sentido miedo
el miedo es una emoción que me dice que
el riesgo es mayor que mi recurso
entonces es muy importante porque lo
dijimos antes se crean de los
pensamientos y sabes que los
pensamientos a veces mienten tenemos
miedos imaginarios de acuerdo el
pensamiento escucha tu miedo es real es
imaginario podés hacer algo
es inmediato o inminente
escucha tu miedo ahí en el miedo hay
mucho por hacer
un concepto para mí fundamental y que es
un paradigma que creo que los años es
decir que al miedo se lo vence
el miedo no sólo vence amigo se le
escucha
me abro a la incomodidad del miedo le
escucho y decido qué hacer
otra emoción para mí fundamental es la
gratitud
la gratitud quiere decir
agradecimiento
algo grato
hay muchos estudios científicos sobre la
gratitud así que lleva tu mente tus
pensamientos a todo lo que tienes para
agradecer la gratitud es como un
limpiaparabrisas que despeja dolores
rencores así que a las 16 hace mucho
mucho ya que todo lo que tienes para
agradecer
acepta
la aceptación la confundimos muchas
veces con la resignación y no es
resignación la aceptación es soltar la
lucha ya que me acuerdo una pequeña un
pequeño cuento familiar
yo soy de río tercero un pueblo chico
donde pasa un río y todas las noches
cuando éramos chiquititos mi papá con
mis cuatro hermanos nos llevaba al río y
nos decía esto
ustedes van a entrar se van a tirar al
agua y en este río
hay muchos remolinos cuando los agarre
un remolino ustedes no luchen o para
tales no griten porque el miedo esa
agitación sin respiración no ustedes
déjense que los hunda que los lleve al
fondo y serás desde el fondo donde
pueden salir gran metáfora de la
aceptación cuando estás en dolor cuando
tenéis miedo
deja que te un gas y desde allí decir
escucha tu cuerpo
se acuerdan los tres símbolos el cuerpo
es hemos mensajero y es canal hay mucho
para hablar el cuerpo pero no me quiero
detener no en un concepto fundamental
convertirte en sobre el jr de la
respiración si sommelier de la
respiración
cada emoción tiene un patrón
respiratorio
por ejemplo uno cuando tenemos miedo
se activa generalmente el modo defensa y
el modo de defensa nos lleva a tres
cosas a pasar el enojo
abrir paralizarte
en el enojo está la respiración
esa respiración establece un movimiento
de neurofisiológico enorme de carga
entonces por ejemplo necesitas
determinación respira
porque el enojo también tiene
determinación necesitas calma respira
calma
la respiración es un manjar que está en
nuestra mesa 23 mil respiraciones por
día hacemos
y podemos gestionarlo soy el sommelier
en la vida
hace un buen maridaje
hay todo este en este banquete
qué respiración tengo que hacer para
despertar mayor bienestar
una y otra vez la vida nos desafía nos
invita a cambiar nos interpela vivir es
estar dispuesto a a tirarnos al río a
nadar a navegar
en momentos hacer la plancha sumergirnos
y volver a salir
vos vos y vos y yo soy un líder soy mi
auto líder me puedo gestionar es fácil
no
es fácil requiere paciencia persistencia
y experimentación y práctica es posible
sí
que cada uno de nosotros sea un líder
como decía gandhi
tú lo que quieres ver en el mundo si
nosotros estamos bien nuestro entorno y
el mundo está mejor muchísimas gracias